there's something about not setting
limits that drives me to want to just
keep going and going and going okay so
if there's something that everyone's
thinking wow this is kind of a real
challenge sign me up for it hello and
welcome to deep dive the podcast that
delves into the minds of entrepreneurs
creators and other inspiring people to
uncover their journeys towards finding
joy and fulfillment at work and in life
my name is ali and in each episode i
chat to my guests about the philosophies
strategies and tools that have helped
them along the path to living a life of
happiness and meaning in this week's
episode of deep dive i chat to youtuber
and iron man athlete natasha osean
frustrated by the gap between the
findings of the scientific community and
evidence-based information reaching the
general public natasha left her phd in
biophysics to start a youtube channel
that tests fitness theories and
translates the science behind health and
fitness she's a master following of over
2 million across her social media and
her goal is to make fitness science
accessible to everyone in our
conversation we discuss her feelings
around quitting academia and her initial
fears about putting herself on the
internet the feeling of
having to get that scientific content
out there to help as many people as
possible so they didn't fall into the
same traps that i did was more important
to me than that initial feeling of being
uncomfortable
and that's why i kept going for it and
practice makes perfect right as well as
uncovering how she cultivated mental
resilience and self-awareness through
athletic performance so i guess the
first thing i wanted to ask you you
famously do these iron man things
like what on earth possesses someone to
want to
swim for two and a half miles cycle for
120 and then run for 20.
why
why do people do this why do you why do
you do this
um well
it was like a part of my life that i
just
i really like setting challenges for
myself just because i feel i feel like
sometimes we can be really prone to
setting limits for ourselves and being
like no i'm not going to do that or i
can't do that and for me like i there's
something about
not setting limits that drives me to
want to just keep going and going and
going okay so if there's something that
everyone's thinking wow this is kind of
a real challenge sign me up for it
because i just i just wanted
i don't know what it is it just drives
me to want to do something that
i feel like in the past i would have
been like i can't do that okay so i
guess that for me is why i chose to do
the iron man
how how did you first get how did you
first get into it well
i
so i used to do
a lot of athletics i used i grew up just
being really active my whole family was
super active so they never kind of let
us play computer games it was always
just go outside play
sign up to whatever you can and just be
as active as possible
so when i was younger at secondary
school i used to do a lot of athletics
but i used to get really badly injured
from it so a lot of the cross training
that i had to do was
in the pool
cycling a lot of low impact exercise
rather than like the hard on the track
sprinting hurdles high jump which gave
me like ridiculously badged influence so
i spent a good nine months doing
cross-training which was
i think my gateway to doing triathlon
because previously to that i hadn't
really done any kind of
much cycling or much i'd done some
swimming but not really
i never really took it to another level
and then when i got to it's really when
i got to university i was i just thought
you know what as well as doing my degree
i also just want to do and man
sometimes there's no real like rational
thinking behind it i was just like i'm
just going to do it because i feel like
that's a real challenge that i can set
myself
by the three years once my three years
is completed at uni i'll do an ironman
and so i just signed up to the triathlon
club and started doing iron man training
okay and it kind of i liked it because
it meant that i also could didn't get
super injured because i was i could
balance out the swimming the cycling and
the running and not do so much high
impact
with the running and then i just ended
up really liking the variety as well
rather than just doing one single sport
so while you were at university and you
know you're you're doing a degree and on
the side you're training for triathlons
and ironmans and stuff like
what did your schedule look like it was
very seasonal okay so um
i'm trying to remember now because it
feels like a while ago yeah
um
so
i did biochemistry so actually we had
loads of lab days so the days were kind
of nine to five for mo for most days
which is quite rare at uni because
sometimes you have just like sporadic
lessons here lessons there like
especially like my english yeah
yeah ours was quite full on and
it would be morning training and then
evening training
about
five six days a week um but
i will stress that during times of exams
i really took that down to like hardly
anything so maybe
seven weeks ten weeks before my exams i
would just
solely focus on revising and learning
because my priority really was just
getting
i wanted to get the first that was the
one thing that i went to uni for that's
the one like i was the first person out
of my family to go to uni so i was like
i need to do myself need to make my
family proud um and so
really like the triathlon was like a
nice bonus but it wasn't no it was
nowhere near as important
um
so
yeah i guess what i mean by seasonality
is that during the time like term times
like the autumn term and then spring
term i could train in the morning in the
evenings
um as well as kind of manage the
manage like the workload from uni
and then
during the
summer term hardly any training okay and
then during the summer break because we
would have really long breaks that's
what i love about uni is you get
amazingly
stupidly long hair and then it was just
like all training okay so then i would
do like no work all training and then i
just get battled sorry see i told you
microphones would get down somehow
um
and
yeah and then there would be loads of
training during summer and then again it
will just kind of go back into that kind
of routine so is is it's true
yeah is it okay is training for these
things fun
is that i yeah so with triathlon it's
quite a social sport okay it's a social
sport with the triathlon club at
university so there was a lot of us and
people do different
disciplines as well so some people would
just be doing sprint triathlons some
people do olympic distance some people
do half ironmans and some people do the
fall but when you train
at uni like you do a lot of the training
together you just kind of get split up
into like a lane that maybe focuses more
on endurance um
and so
that is quite fun because you get to
meet really really great you get to meet
people who have the same interests as
you who understand what it's like to go
through uni and also train that hard
which is something that i didn't share
with my housemates yeah so my housemates
were like why don't you come out and
eventually i start i stopped getting the
invites to come out because they just
they just knew yeah um and then when it
came to doing my ironman actually it's
kind of a sad story in third year
we
unfortunately had to kind of kick not
kick our coach out but there was like
because a lot of the way that sports
clubs are run at uni is that they're run
by students that was kind that wasn't
how the triathlon club was run at the
time it was run by the coaches and they
would pick
compliance students which ended up being
me to be president or yeah and so when
they wanted something done they would
just say can you sign this off
i would sign it off because i just
wanted to please someone and i was
compliant okay and um
and
we started to realize it in in my third
year we started to realize that actually
this is kind of is not right because we
weren't doing we weren't a student club
it wasn't a student-run club it was run
by the coaches who were like in their
40s 50s
and weren't really like they'd gone to
the university but they hadn't they
weren't
affiliate they weren't students they
weren't professors and so that kind of
caused a massive rift like it was too
much drama for me to handle
and that last year became quite a lonely
year because it just meant that a lot of
the training
i mean i hate conflict yeah i hate it
with a passion
so that meant that i would detour my
route to like the to uni or i would just
do a lot more training on my own and so
the training becomes lonely but if you
if you enjoy it it's not that lonely
i i guess it's not
it's less boring than you might think
yeah because it's not as it's not the
same as just saying okay i'm just going
to go out for a cycle like the cycle
rides
are more planned than that so you can
create
routes for yourself where you're doing
hill sprints between that route and in
during those hill sprints you're doing a
particular cadence you're you're putting
out a particular power output and you
always have to hit those power outputs
so in that sense it's more like
think of it as kind of like a really
good spin class but you're outside
enjoying the environment okay and so in
that sense it's not it's not super
boring it's not that repetitive it's
quite repetitive
but it's not as repetitive as you might
think but yeah i mean i did sometimes
take mario and mario as like this just i
don't like this
it's not really for me and i get that as
well because it can it can just be quite
yeah like i tried um i've got a few
friends from from uni who were super
super into the whole cycling triathlon
type stuff they had they had the whole
lycra and everything
and one time one of my friends took me
out for like a i think it was a 15k
cycle and by the end of it like i
couldn't feel my bum anymore i was like
why why is this fun we stopped off at
some like you have to find to be honest
if you find a bad saddle that's game
over okay okay so maybe the saddle is
wrong maybe the saddle maybe the cycling
shorts you need some padding did you
have padding no i was just wearing my
kind of i mean it's game over straight
away
yeah like there's loads of small tips
and tricks that you get learned that you
get taught um over the course of time
where you need to put like chafing cream
on
loads of things okay yeah just make the
whole experience a lot more pleasant got
it yeah that was the stuff i didn't i
didn't get into at all it was just like
this endless cycle like when are we
gonna stop it was like oh we've gone on
the 7k to go like oh my god
maybe they're not friends they might
have just been pulling your leg maybe
yeah thinking yeah let's put him on this
horrific saddle yeah tell him to wear
whatever he usually wears he's never
going to want to do it again
um so so in your third year you had this
kind of drama going on in in the club
which meant that it was kind of a less
social activity but you said that you
enjoyed it anyway so
i still enjoyed it because i had the end
goal of doing iron man so for me and
also i like working in teams but when it
comes to sports
sometimes it hasn't brought out the best
in me
so what do you mean in the sense that
um
i remember playing rounders when i was a
kid
and just
trying to do everyone's job and just
screaming all over the place and it's
just and i think and also i'm very
competitive okay so if people aren't
sharing that same level of enthusiasm
it annoys me
okay but i think i've kind of i've
developed enough self-awareness now to
realize that
i'm i'm like that got it um so i am a
lot better at working in teams but at
the time i wasn't really much of a team
player so solo sports tended to fare
better with me because like because if
something
like if i lost that's only that's only
my fault and i can't blame anyone else
other than myself and i think that was a
good place for me to be in at the time
yeah so very very competitive but you
also don't like conflict yeah and i
guess that can be a a tricky combination
sometimes
but i think i think i'm competitive and
then i just do things that
it's just
i just kind of i'm just kind of working
on myself like with iron man i wasn't
even really going in to do a race i just
wanted to complete it
um
it i was really shocked when i came
second because i
i just wanted to complete it that was
really my goal
um and
yeah i wasn't really going in to compete
with anyone as such yeah on that note
how how do you feel generally about
about goals
goals in relation to goals that are
within your control versus goals that
are potentially outside of your control
like within your control is i'm going to
finish the race to bed the best of my
ability
outside of your control to an extent is
i want to hit a certain time or rank a
certain position or compete with other
people in in a certain way
and often when it comes to kind of
especially like youtube instagram
influencing business that kind of stuff
you know
i think people encourage us to set these
out outcome goals like oh you know let's
aim to hit a certain kpi a certain
subscriber count by a certain amount of
time
yeah which always felt to me as being a
bit like oh but it's not within my
control
yeah
it's like
it very it very slightly is
in the sense that you might have like
luck or you can kind of gear your
content to being more viral
um or more applicable to a wide stream
audience so that it might have a better
chance of going viral yeah but in the
sense but in that sense where it's
something that's out of your control
i mean it's out of your control like i
think over time i i don't really let
that get to me because
i guess i don't get my fulfillment out
of
goals that
can't be that are out of my control as
in if something happens like it happens
that's great but that wasn't
out of any of my doing like if i hit
that kpi i could have just been really
lucky like yeah i worked hard but like
sometimes you're just really lucky and
that's just out of your control and you
can't be you can't be over the moon
about
something that was out of your control
that went your way
because that would just be i don't know
credit where credit is due like yeah
it could have been a 100 other things
yeah and so i guess when it comes to i
don't yeah when things are out of my
control i don't really
i don't really
worry so i don't let it affect me lots
of us go through life with a bit of a
love-hate relationship with stem
subjects in theory the idea of learning
how the world works in science and
learning how to build websites with
computer science is really awesome but
when you're plotting your way through
formulas in a science class or trying to
understand code it can be a bit dry and
boring the way i like to learn more
about this stuff in a fun and engaging
way is with brilliant with kindly
sponsoring this episode brilliant have a
ton of courses that teach maths science
and computer science with visual
examples and interactive challenges
along the way so that you can learn by
doing one of my favorite courses in
brilliant is actually the computer
science series especially the
introduction to algorithms and the
fundamentals of programming with python
i was actually considering applying for
computer science rather than medicine at
university and i ended up going down the
medicine route which i don't regret but
i never really understood computer
science and although i knew how to code
i didn't really understand the
foundational algorithms and structures
behind the field of computer science so
i really enjoyed checking out brilliant
courses on that and also their course on
cryptocurrency is absolutely sick and
without that course i really would not
have understood how bitcoin for example
works anyway if you want to improve your
math science and computer science then
head over to brilliant.org forward slash
deep dive and the first 200 people to
sign up via that link will get 20 off
the annual subscription to brilliant so
thank you very much brilliant for
sponsoring this video so i guess you got
a lot more fulfillment out of the fact
that you finished the iron man than the
fact that you came second in your in
your category okay yeah
what was it like doing it for the first
time the iron man so it was actually
amazing really it was really it was
really fun because the day is organized
really really well okay and you've got
everyone in this i was doing it in
barcelona you've got everyone doing the
same event to be honest i was a bit
nervous because you get a lot of people
that have spent like thousands of pounds
on their equipment and sometimes it
makes you feel a bit insecure because i
i was a student i had absolutely no
money i could barely afford the race so
my bike was a real like
like a patchwork quilt of just people
giving me a tire here a wheel here we've
managed to find this carbon fiber frame
on ebay for about 250 pounds
and me and my coach wired it all
together
and like it really was not a
state-of-the-art actual my helmet was a
skateboard helmet because that was the
most aerodynamic thing i could find
aerodyn aero hat aero helmets are so
expensive oh okay so um yeah everyone
had really amazing kit and that made me
feel a little bit intimidated at first
but the whole day is run
so well like it's done really well
there's always um everyone gets really
excited there's always a really big
crowd as well so it makes you they keep
pushing you right to the end i remember
the marathon which is the slowest
marathon i've ever run because i was
just exhausted that kind of 30 kilometer
mark there was still people out just
cheering you on and it makes you feel
you get energy from that and it really
helps you so that's something you don't
get in training
and so i think it was it made all the
training worth it
nice
and there's like music going and it's
just really well organized so you just
it feels really nice okay
that's really
interesting to hear because i would have
thought doing an iron man it would be a
case of oh it's it's a lot of suffering
while you're doing it and then at the
end you're like oh i'm really glad i did
that but it sounds like you had a nice
time throughout yeah well i think
because i wasn't going in i almost went
in pacing myself i wasn't going in to
win i think if you're going in to win
and you're really going into race it's
savage i i mean to do the iron man in
eight hours
is
it's nuts the speed they're going at the
whole time is i can't fathom it like
it's incredible but um yeah i think if
you're going in it just to complete it
like i was
and you're well prepared and you know
what your nutrition is and you know
you know that you've done all of the
training that you can
then it's and you're pacing yourself i
really was pacing myself like it's it's
fine okay so i was highly recommend
so i was listening to david goggins
audiobook can't hurt me um the other day
and i was like and he talks a lot about
how you know iron man's and ultraman's
and all this stuff and his whole thing
is about how
you know you
you realize the power of the human mind
and unlocking another layer level of
performance
yeah what was that feeling like what's
that feeling like for you when you're
sort of you know halfway through an iron
man you know you've got another half of
it to go
so um i tend to think of things in
stages i i did an ultra marathon last
year actually for a video where i was
running
was it 50k
i think it was 50k
and um
rather than thinking rather than
breaking the
breaking the ultra marathon down into 50
kilometers
or more
i just i created two loops for myself
and i just thought of it as two loops
and i don't know why breaking it down
into not many
[Music]
um
not that meant
also like sections yeah well like just
two things really helped me get through
it and think oh it's not so bad okay
with the iron man i just thought of it
as one swim one bike and a run and so
when i did when i finished the swim i
was like cool i'm a third third of the
way
when i did the bike i was like cool okay
that's the bike done as when i'm and
when i'm doing the bike i'm also
thinking
i'm not thinking about the marathon
after i'm just thinking right let's just
think about getting off the bike
and then when you've and then when
you've done the when you're doing the
marathon i'd break it down into
the laps that we were doing which were
10 kilometer laps and i just thought
right one lap done two laps done three
laps done four done so what's so what's
going through your mind when you
i mean
any time i've tried to do
any run of any kind i get to that point
where i'm like you know what my apple
watch is telling me i've done a
kilometer already my feet are kind of
hurting i could just quit
and often i'm like you know what there's
a there's a coffee van over there i
could get a nice oatmeal glate we'll
have a nice walk home and then and then
i end up quitting
but the people who actually do running
presumably have that thought of i could
just quit and then they just keep going
yeah so what do you tell yourself to
keep going in those moments when your
your mind and body are saying oh you
know but you could just quit do you know
what
that thought never crosses my mind
really that i could just quit okay
it's really weird because
even when i do um
even when i'm training at the gym
quitting
never feels like an option
it doesn't even cross my mind it's like
i couldn't even quit if i wanted to oh
wow i don't even know i don't but i i
don't really know where that comes from
it's just that that thought never
crosses my mind but with the distances
when you're running
i will say that
the more you train for something the
shorter distances feel so yes a marathon
feels like a long run but if you're
going for long runs all the time
it
and your your cat you're always doing a
20 kilometer run you just think oh i'm
just running double that yeah and
distances feel a lot shorter in your
mind
so
so that so that so there is
like a mind training as well that
happens when you when you train for
longer distances where things just feel
shorter in your mind and and does the
sort of
training
training to do iron man's and that kind
of stuff do you find that these sort of
mind benefits translate to other aspects
of your life as well or is it quite like
confined to that one arena of i think it
gives you a lot of mental resilience
okay so whenever
so in that same
vein when i'm saying like i can't like
the thought of quitting just isn't an
option i think of that
in
every aspect of life okay whether it's
when it comes to work
or
relationships or anything like it's just
i mean it depends if it's a really bad
relationship
with a phd
but um
yeah oh yeah my phd i did quit um but um
yeah i guess
it just it gives you a lot of strength
knowing that you've you've done
something you've proved yourself that
you can do something that means that if
you feel
tired or
in a rut or whatever you can get through
it as well
i think but actually one of the things
that i found
i was more
gave me more of that was when i was able
to do a backflip not because like some
people always are able to do a backflip
and it's nothing it's really just a
personal thing for me but i managed to
do a backflip on my own without
assistance and
i don't i'm not going to do it now i was
going to say that that's pretty cool i'd
love to be able to do that but that it
took me two years to get and it was so
emotional for me and i was like you know
what
i managed to do that
and so you just have to keep pushing
through and so i just apply that to
other okay aspects of life if i want
the reward at the end which i didn't for
my phd yeah and that's why i didn't
that's why i quit oh okay so yeah i was
i was gonna ask you about that because
um
i was uh stephen bartlett talks about
this in his book as well where he talks
about kind of a quitting framework
um and his model for this is i think
something like you know will will this
be hard work uh and is the reward worth
it and if the reward is worth it and it
will be hard work then it's worth doing
and if it's gonna be fun then it's it's
worth doing anyway but if the answer if
if it's not worth it then there's no
point in like
suffering through a lot of hard work
that you're not enjoying just for the
sake of this reward that you actually
don't want yeah i agree with that um so
i guess so
you're i think you would have graduated
um undergrad at 21 done the iron man
then and then you decided to start a phd
was it straight after did you have like
a master's in the middle straight after
okay yeah then when when did the
youtubing career start like in this
whole afternoon phd okay yeah i started
doing my phd and there was nothing else
going on okay i was solely focused on
that
and then i saw um have you ever heard of
the banff film festival yes yeah it's
pretty famous yeah yeah i went to uh
most people haven't oh i mean amongst
like the videographer type community
people oh there's youtube videos i watch
it's it's famous yeah i i i went to see
it once and that was maybe six months
into my phd yeah and i remember just
looking at these
amazing camera work amazing stories
being told and i'm always a really
outdoorsy person it's super outdoorsy
and it was just it was incredible and i
sat there and i was like
do i actually enjoy what i'm doing
because prior to that i i had never had
any self-awareness
so prior to that i'd never ever
questioned whether i was happy or not
being honest in my undergraduate i
wasn't really happy like if you'd asked
me straight up how are you yep i
probably would have cried oh wow just
just because that whole question just
opens up so much like how am i i don't
know i'm stressed i'm freaking out i'm
nervous like i'm i'm not happy um and
watching the band film festival was one
of those moments where i just sat and i
thought i don't think i'm doing the
right thing
i think i'm
just doing a phd because
i'm at great uni
um
the reputation is really good at the end
i'll get a doctorate
is that the only reason i'm doing it
and i think
like being self-aware you have to be
completely honest with yourself in a
non-biased way in the moment how are you
feeling
and i and being honest with myself that
was the answer i was purely doing it for
the reputation for the doctor at the
start of my name
not because i was really enjoying it
like if i didn't really enjoy the work
in fact
it's funny because i talk about my phd
and i like the project but i
like doing an undergraduate better in
the sense that i
when you do a phd you become it's very
much about
optimizing for a particular experiment
and you spend six months optimizing for
a particular experiment so you actually
become an engineer of mass spectrometry
you don't you become an engineer like
you know the machine so well yeah but
all that biochemistry that you learn in
undergrad just
it's not important anymore because
you're just trying to optimize for this
one um experiment
and i didn't like that i didn't like
that i was forgetting the biochemistry
that i loved
and that i was just becoming so
specialized in one thing um
and
i it took me like a while to process
what i'd gone through during that band
film festival and slowly slowly over the
course of
another six months i was like yeah no
i'm really doing this for the wrong
reason when i was doing my phd i liked
watching youtube videos i've always been
into fitness
i
but i felt like there was a lot of
misinformation
on
in the fitness industry on youtube
because there was nothing that was
science-backed everything was anecdotal
and
i
had had
i had had i had developed like
relationships with food or relationships
with over-exercising
that i can attribute to social media
because at the time i was really easily
influenced didn't really look at things
critically and just believed
things that were said like if people
said it in a nice way and they looked
really pretty and things like that and
everything looked really nice i would go
along with it and that meant that i
ended up in a position where i wasn't
i wasn't really performing well because
i wasn't training properly i wasn't um
eating properly and and my phd
i think what they didn't do with
my undergrad is we weren't taught to
critically analyze papers but that's
what we did really well
at ucl is a lot of it was really well
analyzing papers look at the methodology
is it flawed how is this study carried
out where is this study published all of
these things make a huge difference and
i realized at that point like there's a
real gap here
there's a gap in on youtube where
there's scientifically based fitness
content that is delivered in a really
friendly accessible way
um
and that's kind of where i started so
once i finish my phd then i sorry my m
phil yeah
i was tutoring and starting to think
about making uh youtube videos okay so
so when you had that moment of kind of
that period of realization where oh
maybe i'm doing this for the wrong
reasons that feels like it would be
quite quite a scary thing because you've
been working for this thing and
following this sort of ladder and then
you're like oh maybe maybe i've been
climbing the wrong ladder yeah and if
if you're sort of side hustle tutoring
what was going through your mind in
terms of like what you were gonna do
with your career what are you gonna do
with your life like were you thinking
about those things before you decided to
quit to be honest i don't think i
it's a weird thing to look back on
because i don't think i was fully
present in that moment
there was a lot of reflection there was
a lot of thinking about the future and
there wasn't much thinking about the
actual present i wasn't i only really
developed self-awareness like a couple
of years later so
in that moment
i think i was just so
flustered that i didn't really
all i knew was that it felt wrong okay
and so in terms of thinking oh is this
going to harm my career or whatever
i didn't worry so much about it okay i
think because i
and i still think this like if i really
want to go and do science again
by all means yeah [ __ ] it like i just go
and sign myself up in like to an
undergraduate and then go through the
whole process again if i have to if i
want to if that is really what
in even 10 years time i decided that
actually i made the complete wrong thing
okay i'll just go off and do that again
like it always felt
like i wasn't closing a door in that
sense
um
and
so yeah i i guess and i was in such a i
was really down
like i think back then like it would
have been depression although i hadn't i
wasn't really seeing anyone for it but i
struggled to wake up i always felt tired
i had no drive to do anything even
things i enjoyed i just what's the point
and so i think because that feeling was
so strong
i just i was just like no it's not right
interesting because like i i often speak
to people who are in the middle of doing
something that they feel like maybe this
was a bad idea uh a lot of the time the
people i speak to are doctors in
particular who are doing
you know practicing medicine and feel
like
maybe i made the wrong toy choice 10
years ago when i decided to go into
medicine it's a really hard one i don't
think the education system here helps us
much because
you have to start specializing when
you're 14. yeah how do you know suddenly
you have to start gearing your work
experience volunteering et cetera
because you've decided i want to be a
doctor yeah your a-levels
all of that starts to just get funneled
down and
as early as the age of 14 yeah when you
have no idea and i think it like doesn't
equip you that well for a like a world
that you need multiple skills like it's
it serves
i think i've done better not being
specialized than being specialized
yeah cause i guess within biochemistry
you could have gone full-on into any of
those like sub-specialties has become a
pro-mass spectrometer forever and that
kind of thing yeah that's what i thought
i was like oh i'm gonna i'm gonna go
into
i'm gonna go into doing biochemistry
then i'll get my phd then i'll get a
postdoc then i'll work my way to
becoming a professor okay that was that
was like my career and then but i think
when i saw that bamf film festival
it reigned because i've
a little bit like you said you were
really creative you did graphic design
right
um my thing was textiles and i
i always i just i love it like i love
the artwork of it i'm not so much like a
no it's not really like the high street
stuff that i like it's really like the
high-end architectural stuff sorry i've
scraped your mic again
um it's really the high-end
architectural stuff where there's just
so much intricacy in it that it's
in so much manipulation of a particular
fabric like that's the stuff that i
really enjoy okay and and um and so when
i saw the bank film festival i was like
well
i want to do something that's more
creative
and i love fitness and i and i
since having done like my mfil i can i'm
now reading all of this scientific
evidence on training and nutrition
that i feel like i've never heard of on
social media that's not the message what
i'm reading here from these papers is
not what's coming out yeah um to all of
us in like magazines on the media et
cetera um and i just i think i knew that
i wanted to be a part of that so much
that it didn't feel like so much of a
leap of faith
i also don't really have i don't really
care so much about what other people
think either
like i really i really don't so my
professors were like a bit embarrassed
that i was leaving because it's not a
thing that you do you don't quit a phd
yeah most people that get a start a phd
they just stick out um
and i think the uni also kind of
looked down on you a little bit but i i
just don't care i was just like i'm
gonna do it so you started the start of
the youtube channel what was like
what happened next what were the early
days like the early days were
beyond cringe
okay i think the first ever video i made
which i've taken down i don't even know
where it is i wish i still had it
um is this halloween fitness video
don't ask me why i did it i just it was
a halloween like skit fitness video it
was horrendous okay but i remember just
going to pure gym at like midnight
filming it on a phone and then that was
my first ever video i think and then
other videos i don't know why that was
my first video i think i was just
thinking yeah let's just do something
like a little bit fun
and then then it started being more um
like
uh informational videos okay but i was i
was really i really struggled with
speaking in front of the camera i was
really camera shy even i i'd say even
like a year and a half in is when i
started getting comments from people
saying oh it feels like your personality
is coming through
because the first year and a half it i
felt so much more comfortable filming
things
and being behind camera
so a lot even like my what i in a days
would be
three minutes long
no talking just
video edited
food being put together
and like just and that's it
and so it really took me a really long
time to warm up to speaking in front of
camera so a lot of the early early days
yeah are just
it's hard to watch yeah it's really hard
to watch because i don't think you'll
find them anymore
[Laughter]
so the the speaking to camera thing um
you know these days i have a lot of
contact with uh beginner youtubers who
wanting wanting to get started wanting
to stay consistent with it
um and one of the prime things that
holds people back is a i'm worried what
my friends and family and parents will
think and b i don't know if i can i'm
i'm i'm not confident on camera yeah um
so you decide to start a youtube channel
despite knowing that you want that
confident on camera
yeah i think because the thing is
i feel like i really had something
to make like there was there really is
there was really a gap for
scientifically based content that
delivered in a really fun way a really
accessible way um and i just felt like
that wasn't being met
but it meant that i really had to go
through
that initial uncomfort but like feeling
uncomfortable about it to get to that
stage okay um
and
yeah i mean even though it was kind of
like unpleasant and awkward and it
i couldn't have anyone else in the room
whilst i talked to a camera it just
because i knew i wasn't being myself i
knew that there was a part of me that i
just i couldn't get it out in front of
camera
and
but because the feeling of
having to get that scientific content
out there to help as many people as
possible so they didn't fall into the
same traps that i did
was more important to me than that
initial feeling of being uncomfortable
and that's why i kept going for it and
the practice makes perfect right yeah
like i personally hate public speaking i
hate it makes me feel so nervous but i'm
still gonna do it because i'm not gonna
die i might die of cringe like looking
back i'll be like oh that was really
badly delivered or you really don't
sound eloquent or whatever it is but i'm
not going to die like it's not the worst
that's going to happen
it's just yeah if people say stuff they
say stuff like i've spent i mean i don't
know if you have siblings i have a
younger brother like you just yeah you
just take the piss out of each other all
the time yeah and
it is what it is yeah um how was the
growth in the early days like can you
remember how many videos it took you to
hit a thousand subscribers or kind of
those
i think the growth was really slow i
mean
the early early videos that because they
were so bad like i
i'm not like i'm not surprised like they
they were just really bad videos like
hard to watch yeah there was some
information but like
someone else has delivered that
information better um
and so i really can't remember i think
i started
in 2000
i think i started in 2016
and
i think by the end of 2016 i don't know
when i started in 2016 but by the end of
2016 and i did one video
which was
kind of like a sometimes you do these
videos that are kind of
you don't necessarily
want to do them but they're good to do
because it gets your channel out there
and that at the time was cheat day
challenges okay so i did a cheat day
challenge that got i think a million
views or something and that grew me my
first 10k
and so and then at the start of 2000 but
i don't know how many videos i'd posted
until then i think maybe i had
maybe
15 videos i'm not sure
something like that so not very many it
was still like a really early channel
um
yeah that grew me 10k and then
and then i i don't fully remember things
really did happen like stepwise though
like i never had like a one
video that just everything took off from
there it just kind of it ha really
happened quite gradually okay which i
actually appreciate because i think
sometimes it's nice to grow with your
audience as well and get to know them
one of the things that i always do with
my youtube videos i try and reply to as
many comments as i can as possible it's
really important for me to feel close to
my audience and i think that also gives
me
the confidence to
to speak to them in a way that i would
with my
to any friend that i have but i really
do treat them like friends because many
of the like comments that i get are
still from people that i've seen from
three years ago
and that have kind of stuck with me the
whole time and so i think getting to
know your
your audience as you grow is really
important and it it made me feel more
confident and it made me feel
because i think if i if it just happened
all in one go
there's kind of like a oh i don't know
what to say
connect isn't there between you and the
audience then yeah like the people who
go viral overnight it's like what do you
do now yeah and i i for that i'm i'm
kind of grateful because i think i would
have struggled the other way yeah
okay even though as a youtuber you're
always like i just
when's that break gonna come like
yeah so in the in the sort of like first
first 15 or so videos where you're not
getting that much traction you're
putting the videos out it feels really
hard you're like oh this is terrible
that that kind of thing what was it that
kept you going um and continuing to make
the videos
even though like video number one wasn't
a viral hit
i think
really like it's what i what i said
before which is that mission-driven
thing of one evidence-based fitness
stuff i just want to help as many people
as possible okay um
i want to help i want to empower as many
people as possible to understand the
science and be able to use that how they
want in their training um so
yeah i'll give i give like recipe ideas
but or but i don't really give
cookie-cutter things it's more about
allowing people to understand the
fundamentals of training training smart
eating properly and then whatever your
diet however you like to train you can
use those principles
and and you have the power because you
know that it's science scientifically
backed and that
because i think i i had got into a
position where i was so confused about
training and nutrition i really didn't
want anyone else to feel that way and so
i felt like it was like my duty i was
like you know this is my calling in life
like i really need to let's get to the
bottom of this like let's really try and
help as many people as possible and
that's why sometimes i did videos that
i
like i
didn't necessarily didn't always
particularly want to do because i knew
that that would
give me the tools to reach more of the
audience like sometimes my titles
will say
like it will talk about fat loss in a
certain way
because i know that at the time
where i was struggling where i didn't
have a clue about what was going on with
like fitness or nutrition i would have
clicked on that title
because someone else will do it and
they'll deliver it with
poor information
and so
yes there's always like a compromise
between that marketing as well okay so
it sounds like you're
you had a clear kind of strong why
behind the thing that you were doing and
that let you be like all right yep this
is just what i'm going to do cause i
have this message that wants to come out
yeah that's interesting um when did how
was it for you
for me my why behind it was a bit more
yeah it was a bit less altruistic um
it was okay it doesn't have to be though
yes i was running a business that helped
people get into med school by teaching
courses for the bmat and ucat and those
exams and things and i thought oh
there's no good free information about
this stuff on the internet
great let me make youtube videos
teaching people how to do this exam
stuff in the hope that maybe if i don't
know 100 people watch this video one or
two of them will think oh this guy knows
what he's talking about let me sign up
to his course so it was started off as a
marketing driver for for the courses but
then very quickly it was like
there were medical applicants in the
comments being like oh can you do a
video about interviews yeah absolutely
sure let's get all my friends on camera
it's giving giving interview tips stick
it on youtube that got traction oh can
you do a video about personal statements
sure
you know that and it sort of grew in in
that way but i always had in the back of
my mind that i don't just want to do
this for fun i want to treat this
properly like a business and so when i
started it was a case of i'm going to
like without fail one video every week
for the next like three years um and see
what happens
and i kind of knew that my first 100
videos were gonna be crap because i knew
nothing about i was about a camera i was
bad at video editing didn't know
anything about anything but i knew that
if i just did enough of it then
eventually i'd get to the point where
the videos might even be decent did you
save the good ideas for later on once
you knew you get that yeah i had one
good idea that i knew was gonna be a
banger it was a video about
evidence-based study tips because this
was something no one ever teaches us uh
i'd done a lot of uh research into that
in my third year when i did a bsc in
psychology so i was like i've got a
banger presentation on how to study for
exams with with all the evidence i just
need to turn that into a video
but that needs to be like my 100th video
rather than my first video because i'm
just not good enough for the video thing
to do justice to this thing
what about you were you holding back
banger ideas there are times now where i
hold something back because
i know that
i know that that
what am i trying to say um
[Music]
like the circumstances will come in
right where like there's
we've got like the right equipment to
film this or we have like the funds to
be able to hire like a specific
like um
not an event a venue yeah sorry
like even the iron man video i've we've
wanted to do that for a long time but i
wanted to do it in right
circumstances so be able to have a drone
be able to do drake footage be able to
hire the olympic pool all of these
things like
the budget is more for a video like that
than a regular um video so some videos
i'll wait just a bit um but a lot of the
videos
i
if i'm making something i make it
so that it's as timeless as can be
so especially with the science the
science explained videos
those i will
i ten it's not i don't feel like i've
had to wait but i will spend a long time
making it
because i know that i only have one shot
like i'm not going to make that video
again
um it's not
some some videos you just can't keep
milking like and and i also
from as a as a creator like i don't like
repeating myself i don't like having to
always do the same thing over and over
and over again like i like to do it do
it really really well to the best of my
abilities and then
cool
i've done that i've done that topic we
can leave that now yeah so yeah so
within within that first year yes maybe
around 2016 time you went to 10k subs
off the back of this um cheat day video
yeah when did youtube start becoming
commercially viable for you what was it
um so i think i hit i think that was
like july 2017.
i think i think i was about like 150k
sucks where i was like okay now i feel
like i can spend a really good amount of
time just focusing on youtube okay and i
can say goodbye to my tutors like my
tutees and it worked quite well as well
because it was like the end of the year
so you don't have to find new people
yeah so it wasn't kind of just leaving
yeah
just before exams yeah yeah and were you
doing
were you doing everything yourself at
the time or did you have an editor like
what was the sort of the um no i think i
was doing everything myself i think
mario helped me a little bit as well
but mainly everything myself okay and
did you know how to edit videos and do
the camera stuff before you started or
no i learned all that on the job just
taught myself yeah i feel like one thing
i'm good at is i'm really quick at
learning so i just i just taught myself
and i wanted it so bad right so yeah you
just you just teach yourself
whatever you need to teach yourself
yeah i find that
you know a lot of um but the editing
wasn't like good at the start
it improved over time yeah you think
it's amazing when you've done it like in
the early days i was like oh yeah [ __ ]
man i've got a crossfade transition yeah
but yeah it wasn't it wasn't amazing
yeah i think like um
generally when i speak to
uh older folk they're always surprised
that oh you know how can you just do
this without a background in that or
without a formal qualification the thing
um whereas i think kind of our
generation and younger just tends to
assume you can just teach yourself
anything on the internet yeah and so who
cares if you've never done video editing
or never known how to use a camera
there's youtube tutorials for everything
out there if you go into that mind yeah
you're right some sometimes i speak to
like people's parents or like older
people and they're like oh wow
what's your qualification on that i
don't have one
i just kind of you just do yeah um and
yeah like you might not be the most
technically advanced or whatever but
especially when it comes to being
creative
i think
even with graphic design i i ended up
teaching myself quite a bit of graphic
design last year and um
i think
luckily i have quite a good eye for
design yeah because your thumbnails are
super aesthetic like all this stuff
happening and it's like now i'm just
taking a lot of effort together yeah
they do take a while to put together um
and
but i think if you have an eye for
something it really helps and then the
technical stuff like comes later i found
that with photography as well because i
really love photography um
i like
taking like arc
more like architectural like neutral
images but i think yeah if you and i
think you just don't set limits for
yourself yeah that goes back to the
thing about the iron man as well yeah
like if you just think you can do it
just keep going for it and just keep
learning and try and learn from the best
and how do you think about
your
sort of personal brand these days in
terms of
kind of mid to long term
like do you
uh
and so for me for example i i'm always
asking myself
you know five years from now ten years
from now what am i going to be doing
i often think am i gonna
am am i still gonna be making youtube
videos in my 40s and 50s that feels
feels a bit weird
and part of me is like hell yeah another
part of me is like yeah but who's he's
gonna want to listen to a 50 year old
making youtube videos so
how do you think about your the
longevity of your personal brand that's
a really good question i actually don't
know if i've
really thought about it too much
i think i'm still at a position where i
have lots of content i want to make so i
don't feel like i'm thinking oh yeah i'm
kind of scraping the barrel here like
and i don't i know if i get to that
stage i think that might be a place
where i go okay let's take a step back
like am i
because i
i find that just kind of i i would find
that very unfulfilling like kind of sad
where it's just like oh
okay i really i have no more ideas like
what i eat in a day version 25
yeah um but i think
i mean especially with your content as
well there's longevity in the content
that you make
in the sense that that there's a depth
to your content so there's more
longevity in it and i think a little bit
the same with me yeah i think that's
something
in the sense that for me i don't think
people tune in to just
watch
me
do a haul
what am i trying to say um i guess
people aren't just watching me for
me and like the current life that i'm
living or
i think
there's more depth to some of the
content that i'm making which has longer
longevity um
which is why i don't over sexualize
myself as well because i think that the
more i do the more i make it about like
physical appearances or things like that
the less longevity
because it's about how you make someone
feel and i want people to feel really
good and i think a feeling lasts longer
with you than just a like an admiration
yeah or you're not deeply thinking about
it i think that's the same for you yeah
i mean as a dude to the whole
actualization
i mean i'd love to have six pack ads
i'm sometimes thinking like if i had
six-pack abs i could do the back flip
slow motion then
um do you ever get that
how
because i guess kind of a female fitness
influencer there's like a certain
aesthetic that does well on instagram
um
do you feel the temptation of like uh
going down the sexualizing route to get
more views effectively
um
that's a really good question i feel
like
there were there are times where i look
at something and i'm like
did that
that really did just do well because she
has a really
big amazing ass or like whatever it is i
don't feel tempted by it sometimes i
think oh it would have kind of been
easier
if we do more
like slightly more sex like more skin
let's just show more skin like let's
show this angle instead but in the long
i think the thing about me is i will
always play the long game yeah and
that's a very short time game to play if
you're going to play it that way it's
very short term because you're providing
someone with like eye candy and that
only lasts for so long and
so i
have always made it a real effort to not
go down that route because
it's just not a long term play and i do
really want to be
in it for the long term um so you've got
like
stupidly large amounts of followers on
both youtube and instagram i imagine you
get people who kind of look up to you as
a as a role model creator er even
outside the fitness space
so what what advice would you give to
maybe someone who is just maybe
graduating from uni not really sure what
they want to do likes the idea of
becoming a creator uh maybe on the side
of their full-time job or whatever
and wants to try and emulate your
success for example what what what
advice would you give being passionate
about something really helps
because just creating something
for the sake of creating i personally
find quite difficult if there's not like
a purpose for creating something um so
going
having something that they
feel really passionate about will come
through in their content as well yeah in
terms of like just going for it like
trying not to worry about what other
people think like it just it holds you
back and then you're only holding
yourself back so if you really want to
go if you really want to be a creator
then just start making something and
don't worry about the first 10 hundred
videos being [ __ ] because they're all
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] for everyone unless
you're an amazing film student which
they've already done their 100 videos
yeah but like at uni because the the
likely the thing is like these your
early videos they don't really get seen
by anyone but you just need to have them
out there so that you knowing yourself
that you've gone through it and it
hasn't just been something that you've
spoken about
spoken about doing like you've actually
gone and done it um so seeing that
project through and also giving it time
i think it's really
i think it doesn't help when you hear
stories like charlie and emilio getting
to five million in like five days like
those stories don't help because that's
really such an outlier
the truth is that these things take a
really long time and you have to be
prepared for it to take a long time and
it's okay if it takes a long time like
whether or not you end up in youtube's
algorithm is up to youtube like it's not
really something you can control like
yeah you can make videos that you think
will appeal to a larger audience but at
the end of the day like if it doesn't
and then it doesn't like there's you've
if you've done your best and you've
really gone for it then that's really
all you could have asked for you can't
really blame yourself don't be too hard
on yourself and especially don't be too
hard on yourself when you're trying to
be a creator because setting up an
environment for yourself where you can
be creative
is
a really important thing i find that i
can't be creative if i'm in the wrong
environment it just
it doesn't float like some people really
good they just as soon as they're on
camera they just switch it on and you
might be one of those people i'm
personally not like i'm i'm quite
emotional in the sense that if i'm in
the mood for filming i'm really in the
mood for filming and things i don't even
have to think about it i'm just like i
know what shot that's going to be yeah
this looks amazing yeah i'm really happy
with this like things just flow
um so if you're creative in that respect
like be self-aware i think
self-awareness is is key for everything
um it helped me so much like in across
life not just making youtube but just
being self-aware just
what do you mean by self-aware because
you said earlier that you weren't
self-aware while you were an undergrad
and it was only after a few years that
you
suddenly became self-aware uh what was
that process like
um so self-awareness is the ability to
look at yourself and how you're behaving
right in that moment in a completely
impartial state
so
and that's a really hard thing to do
like if you're feeling angry
imagine yourself in a third person
looking at yourself and being like
you're being angry like you're a dick or
like you're behaving like a dick like
when you're in that moment and you're
frustrated and you're angry and you're
that emotional it's hard to
to think
okay i'm being really angry why am i
angry or what can i do about it
that i think is
that i think is what self-awareness is
um
i think for me it started off with
self-reflection
where i would behave in a certain way
and then
i'd look back and be like oh yeah i kind
of behaved
really badly or like or however like too
emotionally or um and it's i think the
process of being self-aware is to take
that emotion out and be really honest
with yourself and not worry about is is
it that right
it should i have behaved that way like
and it is part of understanding your
personality and then once you can
understand your personality you can
you can find solutions for yourself and
set things up for yourself that help you
in your life
literally across all of your life like i
think the first time i ever
developed self-awareness was i was
seeing a life coach and um he
specializes in neuro-linguistic
processing and
i
was frustrated i was for straight
because i was always arguing with my mum
and we were always always always
fighting always
about the smallest things and i and i
said this to him and he was like okay
let's let's practice and let's do some
self-awareness i was like what do you
mean it's her fault it's not my fault
it's her fault and he was like and so
we started to kind of like work through
that and i started to realize how i was
feeling in the moment and what i could
do about it and it's really about taking
control of how you feel in that moment
and what you can do about it
impartially and i think it makes you
feel
i think over time it's made me
a lot better at
being a creator as well um
and a lot better at
balancing life and feeling aware of
being self-aware of how i'm feeling in
the moment so talking about balance
like i don't think i've i don't think
that balance is
something that i
um
practice every single i practice it
every day but i don't have balance every
day in the sense that i don't have like
i don't get my work out and i don't get
my like rest time and i don't get my
every day it doesn't work that way it's
kind of kind of snakes around
and you go through moments of imbalance
and moments of like balance and then in
the in the middle you're sorry you've
got you go through moments of imbalance
you go through moments of like
on both extremities and in the middle
you find balance okay um and that can be
over like the course of a month or a
year
like in the last six months
when i wasn't posting youtube videos i
was working a disgusting amount it was
disgusting and i wasn't getting enough
sleep and i wasn't working out how i
usually work out and i wasn't doing all
these things and i was self-aware
because i knew that that was an
unsustainable way to work and so what
can i do about it i knew that
i had to work in that way but it wasn't
something that was sustainable and so i
need to find a solution to start to
bring that back in and so i knew that i
had to find a date at which i needed to
start slowing things down i booked
myself a holiday and then i start
getting back to moments where i feel
like
more in balance catch up on sleep start
training finding more of a routine but i
think it's being aware in that moment
how you feel being really honest with
yourself completely and partially
as if you're just a third person you
didn't even know that person looking in
on the situation and thinking right how
are you behaving yeah how are you acting
how do you feel why do you feel that way
what can you do about it
and it's different from self-reflection
yeah so it has to be in that moment in
that moment that's a really hard part
okay and i guess in that moment you
sort of take your own feelings seriously
and seriously ask yourself okay what
what has happened to kind of make me
feel this way exactly so it's not about
shutting that emotion out you have to
feel it
but be aware that you're feeling it and
thinking and think about the environment
that's around you and thinking okay why
do i feel this way what can i do about
it and kind of really taking control
because i think before
there were a lot of things where i was
like oh i
why why is this happening to me blah
blah blah and in
most of those situations
the cause was always me
and it's just about being really honest
and not feeling like embarrassed like
some things it's hard to be honest you
know when you're answering like a
personality test and it's like i
wouldn't do that but secretly you do
yeah and it's okay if you don't think
it's a good thing you just have to be
really honest with yourself is the only
way you get to like the root of it do
you spend much time on social media
uh yes large amounts
but i choose not to oh okay it doesn't
make me feel good okay like and i'm
self-aware to know that it doesn't make
me feel good so because it doesn't make
me feel good i just
all i do is i just create the content
that i want to create and also i tend to
find that
seeing too many things
especially in a similar field
starts to cloud my judgment where i was
i'm like i'm doing well on my own like
i've found my feet like i know what i
want to create i don't
necessarily need external
cues as to what i want to make and i
think that's a danger especially with
fitness
where
people are looking too much what other
people are doing and they all start to
become one
and you start to lose
as a follower you start to think well
everyone's just kind of the same like
you followed a person for a reason if
everyone feels the same you've ruined it
for everyone
so
that's why i don't spend so much time on
social media
or anything like that because i just i
don't
it doesn't make me feel good and it
doesn't help me in my content okay but
then i try and make content that does
make people feel good
so i'm always trying to make content
as like a as like an anti-content like
the content that i
because a lot of the content just
doesn't make me feel good so i'm
thinking what is it about that content
doesn't make me feel good and i might
get it wrong sometimes um but i always
try and make content that
would make someone feel you know some
people just have that vibe where you
look at their page or you look at their
content and you're like
oh yeah it's like it's really nice and
nice yeah this is really nice some
people really have that and so i tend to
stick to those people and then i yeah i
don't spend so much time on it how
how how do you come up with ideas for
your own stuff for my instagram for for
your own stuff on my own stuff like
youtube because once you've been doing
it for five years
you said that you've you've got loads of
ideas like how how do you come up with
them how do you save them like what's
your process for that
sometimes it's sometimes some videos are
more like
they're situational also it's things
that have happened in my life that i
think okay this can be quite helpful
it's something that i've never thought
about speaking about my back injury was
something that i would never i never
thought i'd speak about
because i'd never had a back injury and
i hadn't really had an injury that has
impacted me so much in my training
and so that's
that i kind of draw inspiration from
events that have happened um
and i and also sometimes with content
also i like to keep up to date with the
science so if there's like a paper that
i'm particularly like
interested in or i see something that
they've mentioned that's unusual i'll
have a look at it um with nutrition
there's so many things you can talk
about i think the thing that i try and
do is i try not to put myself in a box
so
as much as
as much as i am in kind of the fitness
space
i can also dig into wellness i can also
dig into
like the broader
like how do you integrate health and
fitness into a lifestyle or like a more
productive lifestyle there's i and also
like actually creating just being
creative like i guess i don't
like to put myself in just like a
fitness box and that's all i do and
that's all i specialize in um because as
a creator i think that makes you
i think that narrows you down whereas
rather than narrowing stuff down it's
good to keep your your eyes open
to what's going on around you and so
um and so i would say like looking at
things with the fitness industry from a
business perspective um and
i like i have lots of different
interests from different fields
that
i
try and draw into my own content okay
so
i think there's a there's a balancing
act there where
a lot of the traditional advice on how
to grow on youtube would say that you
want to find your niche and you want to
stick to your nation stick to your lane
and niche down to blow up
um
and yet at the same time when you have
like a sort of a personal youtube
channel like you and i do where we have
all these different interests and we
want to talk about them
do you
do you ever feel that tension that like
well i maybe want to talk about this
thing but ah i'm
i'm sort of in the fitness health
wellness space and i'm maybe not allowed
to talk about that thing do you
do you worry about that at all yeah
sometimes like yeah i do get that okay i
do feel like sometimes like there'll be
a vlog that i want to make that i'll
have to word in a particular way or like
mark it in a particular way
so that people don't feel like it's too
much of a change from the other content
that i make
um
but
on the whole i don't think i've reached
that point too much
yet i still feel like i have a really
solid amount of content that i want to
make um
and
there's a lot of collaborations that i
want to do as well and that helps as
well bring in like widen
the space as well nice i don't know did
that help do that no yeah no that makes
sense um i was gonna ask so you so you
said that when you were going through
your undergrad if someone had asked you
how are you you would have kind of burst
into tears because like that's a big
question yeah um and you and you said
that you're not you weren't particularly
happy back then yeah do you do you think
you're you're happy now
yeah okay yeah i'm really happy now
i think i think before i like i was
saying i had no self-awareness so that
meant that i would continually have four
hours of sleep
and not do anything about it
because i just in the moment didn't
wasn't being honest with myself like are
you tired 100 yes
but i didn't ever take a step back and
think
right this is how you sort the problem
out all i kept doing i just kept doing
the same thing just on repeat
so
being able to develop self-awareness for
anyone i think is like just is so
helpful
it helps you in realizing like who you
are what environment works best for you
i'm more of an introvert as well so
surrounding myself by lots of people
doesn't help me
i like
sometimes just having real alone time or
just being around people who
just don't draw lots of energy out of me
and i think
being self-aware you can be honest with
yourself and manage your life so that
things work better for you
what are the bits of your life where
when you don't have them you feel like
okay i'm i'm a bit off balance
i'm i'm i guess what i'm trying to get
at is do you find that you're happier
when when when you train during the day
do you find that you're happier when you
i don't know get eight hours of sleep
like have you figured out what those
things are for yourself yeah so you're
more content and happy and stuff yeah so
i'm just naturally quite an active
person i like being active i don't
necessarily have to be in the gym but i
like being active and i also like being
outdoors um
and yeah i i function so much better if
i sleep better so yeah
basic things yeah yeah those basic
things like i think that's why
that's why i really like your office
yeah it's why i like the place that i
chose um to live in because it's got
lots of light and i don't feel like
i i feel like i can see the outside and
it makes
it might not make a big difference for
other people but for me it really makes
a difference
um just to feel like i can just see the
outdoors
yeah i i noticed myself i kind of
struggled during covid because
that whole restriction of like being
able to go outside and like going out
and doing things that i know helped me i
couldn't do so
that's why i like i did struggle during
covid um
but
yeah i think as long as you just keep
working on that self-awareness it really
helps amazing
um so i've got a few questions to end
with
which are more like um
sort of rapid fire in the sense that um
the questions are rapid but the answers
don't necessarily have to be
so if we're down to just sort of go in
in random directions okay um so
what advice would you give to your
younger self start practicing
self-awareness straight away
amazing okay who's had the biggest
influence on your career
uh mario okay so um
so
he has any
he's one of those people
that is
emotionally intelligent and just
intelligent like just baseline um
he
has always had really good
self-awareness so he's really been able
to like assess situations but just more
than that like he's taught me so much
about
business about
managing myself managing my life he is
my manager um
how to work effectively productively um
how to manage relationships how to
yeah just he's
yeah it mario for sure
always great
um what's one tip for someone who's
looking for success be prepared to work
really hard
and you have to make sacrifices
in order to get there like it's not
i don't think success comes without
sacrifice
oh interesting
would you disagree no that's a nice
quote success doesn't come without
sacrifice um
i don't know so there's a big well
there's a sort of uh movement these days
a sort of the anti-hard work movement
okay um and i think interesting i think
like it's like um to be successful yeah
is it an anti-hard worker to have a nice
life or is it an anti-hard work to be
successful i think it's an anti-hard
work to have a nice life rather than to
be successful which is where the where
where the nuance is but i guess kind of
back in the day uh kind of i'm thinking
gary vaynerchuk kind of vibes of like
you gotta hustle you gotta work really
hard it's so that you can build a
business etc
and
especially kind of post-pandemic
um it seems like the idea of hard work
and hustling and productivity in in some
spheres is getting a bit of a bad rep
that hey we shouldn't be promoting hard
work we should be promoting healthy
living and all that kind of stuff
and
and the way i always think of it it's
like well it kind of depends on what
your goal is like if you want to win
gold at the olympics you know you aren't
going to get there without like
sacrificing a lot of things along the
way but if you want like a pretty
chilled out nice balanced life then by
all means go for it i think it's
important for
for people and this is certainly what
i'm trying to do is figure out like what
do i actually want here what am i
optimizing for i think i've gone through
that same phase as well where
it
there was a point where
i actually had not an argument but just
like um
speaking about it with with my cousin
who i'm really close to and she was like
i feel like i
i never see you
and that's
and i think at that point i was like oh
[ __ ] like i've sacrificed so much that
the people that i love like i just don't
see
like i i don't have time for i'm not
making time for them so there is there
is that i think
maybe instead of like i think also you
have to work smart
so
one of the things that i used to do when
i was younger is i would work really
hard but it was so [ __ ] inefficient
like i i don't know what i was spending
my time doing it just was not efficient
so i think being really smart with how
you
work and spending time doing the right
things and
especially with fitness like
there's a seasonality to it i'm not
going to make a ton of fitness videos
around christmas time waste of time
complete waste of time january okay
march okay but like around christmas
time like i'm not i'm just not going to
stress myself out with stuff that people
just aren't interested people want to
enjoy christmas i want to enjoy
christmas like it's just not the right
time to be putting
all of your effort into doing something
when it's just not going to give you
that much return
um
so i think working smart is
a smart way to go what does the first
and last hour of your day look like
first hour of my day looks like
just
first hour is emails i just keep
checking my emails
um which kind of isn't an amazing thing
to do right this is like very present um
it's not an amazing thing to do to just
wake up and look at your phone but i am
guilty of it and um last
hour of the day
i'm just a potter i just potter around
just check the plants oh nice like take
ages
like ages brushing my teeth just doing
things that's not really anything that's
my last hour fair play that seems very
countered to the
i mean i would have expected a wake up
of five do a meditation do we go for a
run that whole
sort of
the whole thing yeah a lot of people
think like people have very much have an
idea of what health and fitness looks
like um
but ain't nobody got time for that not
if you want like no if you want to also
have like a working life and stuff like
that like i can imagine that for like
the retired
the retired like feel good retreat kind
of life but no i don't have time to do
all of that
what material item under a hundred
pounds could you not live without john i
think that i couldn't live without i'm
quite good at stripping things from my
life
what's yours maybe that'll give me an
idea oh that's a good question um
your glasses maybe they're above 100
yeah no i think um
i guess the way i i i think of it it's
like what's a
like a thing that has that sort of
underrated that people don't
oh so for me at university it was like a
five quid door stop i would just like
wedge my door open at all times and my
social life was ten times more
interesting than if my door was closed
by default so like
that little thing had such an enormous
impact on my uni experience that i now
recommend it to everyone oh before i
just get draw stuff that is a nice one
um
i guess i would say
my diary oh you have a diary yeah is it
like physical diary yeah well i i
i used to keep a diary from when i was
about five
to eighteen strict it's actually really
crazy reading back
it's like crazy um
and now i kind of enter into it every
like now and then i don't i don't
journal yeah it's more just like
when i'm really feeling something like
i'll just write right right
but yeah i have a diary nice do you have
several diaries like a whole yeah you've
got a whole collection yeah a whole
collection and do you find it uh it's
it's helpful to kind of process your
thoughts i think it's helpful yeah
especially because the process of
writing like really slows down yeah it's
not like typing
yeah it really just slows everything
down yeah yeah i i find it helpful also
because it's no one is ever going to
read it
well hopefully yeah hopefully no one's
ever going to read it so you can really
just put whatever you want and then you
can really be like okay that's
you're being over the top there or or
however i just find it quite therapeutic
i just like getting my ink pen out for
it so yeah it's nice oh very fancy
um if you lost everything how would you
start a business again sounds really i
don't know if it sounds really arrogant
i feel like i could do anything i could
be of service to anyone also i have no
embarrassment of
doing like a like i don't have a oh i
can't do that kind of job like i i used
to clean i used to
um
i used to work as a lifeguard like as in
i
i've done so many jobs i used to be a
waitress like i used to just do like
pots and pans i used to just go around
and clean people's cars like i don't
have any embarrassment of what job i
need to do so i'll just start from there
build up invest i don't have a i don't
have much of it
i don't spend a lot of money like i'm
not really much of a spender just save
and invest and
and just go about it from there really
amazing um what book would you recommend
to everyone just one oh well one two
three like i'm always interested in
maybe one thing
the one thing oh yeah gary keller yeah
yeah um mastery
mastery robert greene i think so yeah
and quiet
quiet quiet is a really good one
actually that one with topic yeah oh
interesting yeah cause i guess you
identify as an introvert so that's like
a very introverted type book i also feel
like it's really relevant nowadays
especially for like especially
well especially in my industry for
social media in social media like people
say things with so much confidence
doesn't mean they're right like not
everyone should have
not everyone
if you don't know about something you
shouldn't be speaking about something
because you just don't know that i don't
talk about stuff i don't know because i
don't know it would be wrong with me to
talk about it um and so i think it's
important in this day and age nice
um what quote or mantra do you live by
there's one from elena roosevelt which
is it goes along the lines of um
you won't worry so much about what
others think about you if you realize
how seldom they do
nice
yeah that's a good one yeah it's a good
one what's yours if
um mine is probably um a journey before
destination
i think i've heard you say that before
actually it's one of my usual spiels i
just love it i just think it applies to
all areas of life um yeah what's your
take on that journey or destination
general destination um
i have fallen for the just reached the
destination don't worry about the
journey like i i think i if like being
honest with myself have gone into things
where i
the journey is [ __ ]
but at the end i'll get somewhere um i
think it's just about measuring like
where that's except where the light like
if that's an acceptable
way to live by things for certain in
certain circumstances when it comes to
your life
it probably helps to go through like the
journey because yeah and the journey
teaches you so much as well
like i think
that's the whole thing about
like success
like
overnight success can sometimes be
really harmful because you can learn so
much from the journey
yeah and yeah the way i think of it is
like
the journey is is really all that we
have at the end of the day
like i don't know about you but but for
me when i kind of accomplish a goal
there isn't really any sort of lasting
satisfaction from that
and it's more about that huh you know
the friends i made along the way was it
fun in fact that kind of thing
did i learn something do you think
because do you are you one of those
people who once you've achieved a goal
you just kind of shrug it off yeah i
think i'm really bad at celebrating wins
and things just like all right cool
that's fine it doesn't change my day
i'm still gonna grab a cup of coffee
still gonna make a video like the i i
feel like whatever happens i'll just
potter around doing doing my thing
yeah
yeah i think i think
i also do the same where it's like i'm
not very good at celebrating an
achievement i just kind of
yeah on to the next cool
keep moving yeah yeah
um so yeah thank you so much for coming
on it's been it's been an absolute
pleasure um we'll put links to all of
your things in the video description in
the show notes whether people are
watching or listening to this um
where i guess yeah where can people find
you any projects you want to shout out
or drive try and uh
get some people to check out
um so you can find me on youtube you can
find me on instagram uh you won't find
me on takedown
um
not yet anyway and
um yeah i work with dietitians if you're
looking for training programs that are
scientifically backed i've got your back
and
that's pretty much it sick